there is no past and there is no future
there is just now
we're being told what I ought to believe
I'm tired of being told how I ought to
see how I ought to behave how I ought to
feel
let me find out to myself Who I Really
Am
when a person reaches a certain point in
life when he says now look here
I've had enough of all this
I'm simply tired of making life not in
the least bit worth living
by going through the Horrors
as to what might happen
after going through all this in the name
of efficiency and membership in the
community
led me for a while get away from it all
and about the scores for myself only
suckers
put hope in the future
so when we say to ourselves
you must go on
the reason is you see
that we are not living in the Eternal
now
where reality is
we are always thinking that the
satisfaction of life will be coming
later
don't kid yourself
the only place to begin is now because
Here's Where We Are
so why put it off
a lot of people say well I'm not ready
what do you mean you're not ready
what do you have to be to be ready
you look at yourself honestly
you'll find that inside you're actually
a quaking mess of sensitivity
so that this desire to be the great
Mystic is nothing more than a symptom of
your quaking mess
it's self-defense running away from the
quaking mess
caping
there's nothing
you can actually do
to transform
your own nature into
unattached
selflessness
because you have a selfish reasons for
wanting to do it
no suppose there's nothing
we can do to change ourselves
Psychotherapy religion all this is
absolutely insane
there's nothing nothing you can do about
it by trying as I said about your own
teeth what does it mean that you can't
do anything about it
singing loud and clear the reason you
can't do anything about it is that you
don't exist
that is as an ego as a soul a separate
will just isn't there when I say you as
you concede yourself to be that is your
ego your image of yourself isn't there
exists it's an abstraction
who is pushed around by its fate because
it's all together disappeared
and so in likewise the illusion of the
ego who pushes fate around has also
disappeared
there's a Happening by dying to
yourselves
by having become completely incompetent
and found that you don't exist you're
Reborn
see our problem is we don't really know
how to stop we've got something started
and we see it's going in the wrong
direction
and I think the difficulty is when the
wrong man uses the right means the right
means work in the wrong way
in other words there's something wrong
with the way we think
and while that is there everything we do
will be a mess
now what is it that's wrong
now as far as I can see
the basic mistake is
that we've invented this wonderful
system
of language and calculation
and that it is at once
too simple to deal with the complexity
of the world
and also we are liable to confuse that
system of symbols with the world itself
just as we confuse say money with wealth
a lot of people are in business to make
money instead of wealth when they make
the money they don't know what to do
with it
the Civilized man tends to be a mistake
of chronic Wally and fear and anxiety
because he's always confronted not with
the simple actuality of what is
happening beforehand but with the
innumerable possibilities of what might
happen
and since the cause of this is emotional
existence tends to be in a chronic state
of anxiety and tension he loses
increasingly
the ability
to relate
the two the concrete world as it
manifest itself to him
we are all amazingly involved in the
process of being human and playing our
game and taking our side
and therefore our victories and defeats
our sicknesses and our healths
[Music]
are things we get Mighty partisan about
and therefore we cannot see that human
behavior
is just like everything else
it never makes a mistake
only
it's never making a mistake must include
the feeling that mistakes can be made
all people are manifestations
there are not any mistakes in the world
when you look at patterns on the phone
of
the breaking waves on the seashore
when you look at the outlines of
mountains
the Grain in wood
and the markings on marble
you notice that it never makes an
aesthetic mistake
never
life
happens changes go on too rapidly for
that
because you see in the world everything
is happening all together everywhere at
once
and meanwhile we with our myopic little
minds are working it out step by step
because we are greatly assisted by the
rapidity of the computer
but even so the computer is still
looking at things in rows as the
Magnetic Tape goes through and is
scanned by the computer it's still all
going along in a single track
and I suppose there are difficulty is
that we have lamentably one-track minds
and an infinitely many tracked universe
and we may have to come to the alarming
conclusion that the universe is smarter
than we are
when you study the records of these
self-discoveries the fascinating thing
is
that there seems to be such a common
measure of agreement
between all those who find the option
themselves
and yet always the way in which she has
to find out is not through seeking
agreement with others not trying to find
what others have found
but only to find what his own senses and
his own direct experience tell him when
he as it were goes into his inner covet
goes into his own secret place and asks
for
direct encounter with the world and no
longer as it looks out of the corner of
his eyes to see if everybody else is
doing the same thing getting the same
results
it is a good sense that the person
becomes obturous
turn through the word himself
an original
authoritative source of life as distinct
from the person
in its original sense
a mask
a role that he is playing in the society